well heidi ho reject nation we're here for
stranger things episode four today excited
to check this bad boy i've been loving season
four so far uh guys full length watch along as
we sync it with the time code available for a
super sexy rejects that patreon cover a whole
bunch of shows over there where at the same tier
you also get the option for reaction highlights
included exclusively for some of those shows
if you can't do that please leave a like and a
comment that helps us out on the algorithm very
much thank you thank you thank you and also uh
subscribe and click that notification bell to
get notified when our reaction for the next
stranger things episode is up and then boys
at prepper you guys are hard at work gonna
be getting this done without y'all while we're in
the middle of moving so thank you let's get to it
what's doing these killings that's what we're
trying to ascertain in the meantime it is a
vital importance that you do not speak to
anyone about this no no way i know this is
difficult to understand it's not difficult this
is impossible we're friends of owens 11 trusted us
now we're asking the same from
you smoke some putt calm down guys
it was here a grandfather
clock you've been marked max
chrissy's headache started a week ago read six
days ago i've been having them for five days
i don't know how long i have probably like
another day looks like i'm gonna die tomorrow
stay here the hell was that
it's probably the janitor
they all hooked up
sorry guys i'm spiking for eight miles wow that's
an adrenaline rush you're in terrible danger
all right yeah that definitely sucks but
we've got bigger problems than jason right now
the love of your life is gonna die and
it's what are you gonna do to save her
is lucas home negative do you know where he is
we were supposed to go out go out i
see he's taking a step down for max
i ain't trying to kill someone right now do you
know dustin henderson know him i've bled with him
please tell him i've been covering for his
ass for two days now each day of covering
costs 10 bucks with a dpr that's the
daily percentage rate of 7.9 percent
another week of this and he's
buying me a goddamn nintendo
with duck hunt and a duck hunt gun how did fekna
get through oh and how's it getting through now
and why now and why then just pops out
in the 50s kills one family he's like
yeah i'm good poofy just disappears just yeah
like penny wise hey it's kind of like pennywise
dude it's just like pennywise we have a plan
thanks to nancy's newspaper minions we are now
rock star psychology students at the university
of notre dame i'm now ruth and i'm rose ruth
she looks like a ruth yeah but for what is
essentially a ransom exchange for that for that
i think you very much need to be on time in
the most patriotic motel why aren't you tense
murray's probably dreamed of making a drop for
years all goes well for tomorrow night you're home
eating answers with your
sexy woman she's not my mom
of course not she saves your
life because of friendship
must be pretty for your woman he's not my
woman hit his feet yeah break both of his legs
you're not under arrest great no no you're
you're here to protect us and watch tv apparently
weed withdrawals if you keep staring at that
it's not going to change yeah you're right
well i mean you don't that's not throw it out yeah
we never fight i mean we fought before but
just like silly fights stupid fights but
i don't know this one just felt more adult like
it it just felt more real like we came of age i
would say that man looks like it's gonna be up
to us again it always is isn't it which is why
we can't stay here oh jonathan's getting in the
action yeah buddy we make everything fresh here
at surfer boy except for our pineapple which
comes from a can but i still highly recommend
slapping some juicy pineapple on your pot justice
for pineapple oh my god what an answer hello
oh those goodbye letters i know
you guys are staring at me sorry
why don't you guys play simon if we go
to east hawkins will this story pin hers
of course wait why are we
talking about these talkings no
you know what's happening you just
gotta stop saying no to stuff anderson
that's super wacky of yours better
reach panhars every time he gets asked
to babysit he ends up being the worst
babysitter someone should listen to him
i can't breathe in this thing and i'm
itchy i'm itching all over it's not all
about comfort okay we're academics who are
evidently coming straight from an easter run
to say they look like super christians i know very
quite well actually oh good those who get to teach
yes that's actually why we're here i mean
we can only learn so much in a classroom
and i'm sympathetic to your struggle
julie but there is a protocol
i'm breaking out in a rash my boobs hurt and
i'll tell you the truth anthony may i call
you anthony these aren't actually my clothes i
borrowed them because i wanted you to take us
seriously because nobody takes girls seriously
can i tell you a story 1978 summer camp
and my counselor drew told me and everyone
in cabin see the true story of the victor creel
massacre and little petey mchugh you know peter
other kids they wanted to be astronauts basketball
players rock stars but i wanted to be you
but don't tell me that crybaby petey mchugh
wouldn't have gotten an audience with victor
in a matter of moments if he'd asked politely
because you and i both know that he would
i'm back in 30. damn robin boom mary you
use that that over talking to your advantage
marry you ruth mary right no i don't
know i think maybe getting rocky
dude these snow shots are beautiful
like you get those little particles
of snowfall you must be dicey just choice murray
hope you do not mind if i count you
two seem very nice very trustworthy
his name was currying
you're the craziest one here hopper
nice i would stab him in the face
let's do it let's do it
rip the band-aid of all your foot skin off
oh [__]
okay
don't fire the gun don't fire the gun
whatever you do for the love of christ
nice
oh please keep it indoor keep it indoors
oh my god oh ow ow nice oh jesus
oh very cool yes
oh my god he's gonna run barefoot sure just
add a little more salt to all these wounds
god damn jesus
son of a [__] classic hopper
more like rudder haha guys
she got a lot of writing done i know if she lives
she should write a feature film she's going to
have to have a lot of awkward conversations
yeah if they find this it's just a lot
um i i left some letters inside letters i i don't
understand what if something happens to me max
baby nothing is going to happen to you i know but
if it did nothing is going to happen baby promises
oh [__] oh not now not here
whoa wow what a manipulator
she wasn't even helping she wasn't
even only picked the whole thing
did something happen please just go so
open up a tad bit please just a tad bit
they might need the clues yeah for when stuff
happens to them so excited to speak with victor
preferably as she said alone now you guys
are coming across like groupies cultists
yes why not you've caught me in a rebellious
mood and there's something rather urgent i need
to check on any he's gonna call professor
brentwood yep yep yeah professor branbox
well hello clarice and clarisse
clary sees you got visitors
real pretty ones oh yeah don't
do that bad don't do that
i'm half expecting one of those nails to just
come right off stop you're pissing me off
cut it out man
i don't talk to reporters whatever
killed your family we think it's back
oh no whatever it is i
i think we should work together i think
it'll be easier for we're a team friends
that's will's been looking for that
waiting for you i look for you my way to
hear these words for two whole seasons
hello there whoa oh my god stay here what's a
what a rude awakening jesus christ what's going on
we gotta go what the hell is going on
now it's found footage
damn you're good at your job my dude is competent
jesus never what is the water golf again
he is taking out the military right now
one man wrecking machine it's the mustache
oh oh you knew this was coming pete my cop
just earned my respect by a million percent yep
guess that lady at the top was telling the truth
that was quite a wonder how about
39 980 so uh no deal let's recap
naruto run hopper
huh
he never discovered the demogorgon no
not once maybe they'll have to go back
haunting religious 80s music
i wonder how much they paid
for it not to be skippy
he ratted them out oh no you son of a [__]
oh my god you gotta be kidding me
oh the guard
no oh damn it no [__]
man this season is something else yep it is so
intense wow this is amazing it looks like a fairy
tale a dream yeah a grim fairy tale we had one
month of peace in that house and then it began
always what did the animals
do was the spawn of satan
first it canceled the water building oh my god
yep yep yep i began to have encounters of my own
they hate that music nothing
scarier than pleasant oldies
wow it took virginia first
oh my god that is horrific only to find
myself in a nightmare for our worse
oh boy why vac now let him live he clearly
had so much guilt if you can even hear this
they really hope that you can the clouds
are changing i'm so so sorry billy
i love your shitty little sister max
look at the clouds yeah oh damn
this guy's like freaking vincent
price max time to giddy up yeah max
max
that wanted me to die that day really no it's
not true that's why you stood there isn't it
god the church bell
it is time
oh [__]
oh
hatch said that music can reach parts of the
brain that words can't so maybe that's the
key a lifeline a lifeline back to reality oh my
god play some music for max yeah keep talking
dustin it's robin holy [__]
finally please please please
tell me you guys have been
figured out ella fitzgerald
oh man
no myers meyer's grave
oh no god it's like some sam raimi's [__]
what is this her song what's your
favorite song why robbie said if
you listen it's so much to explain
right now what's her favorite song
this is for some kind of ritual
oh my god guys
oh good song choice too
spit in his face
no i don't want a letter we're
right here i'm right here
oh yeah
oh jesus
run up that hill damn it
come on you [__] show you
thank you oh [__] oh most
satisfying not cut to credits ever
great reprise beautiful shot good job sean lovey
confirming you're a bully wagner
clown clown you're a clown you're
clown clown you're bullied clown
god i'm exhausted
i thought they were gonna do
some classic stranger things
like let's let's let them tune in to
the next episode yeah i've come this
far don't do it i like that the episode
actually does just end with that little
bit like that was very i think self-aware
choice on their part but i appreciated it
who daddy oh buddy or something all right got
a few more episodes to get through here so
ah yeah we'll keep it short the best weekend
we always say uh this is i don't i have no idea
what that actress's name is still sadie sync
yeah he plays max yeah yeah she's uh she's
incredible she's fantastic yeah an incredible
former beautiful monologue and it's so
real it's like such a real performer
plays that repressed personality difficult
to open up character so well so so realistic
and uh yeah you do some [__] of of love and
hope saving the day you're gonna get me man
you're just gonna freaking get me right there
anytime someone is like in a desperate dash to
just get back to the people they love and have
just now learned again to appreciate like oh
yeah man i like i like when when uh like an action
scene or some kind of set piece can also get me
very emotional like when the story really does
collide with the action in a very visceral way
yes and it it they they make a powerful there's so
much emphasis on music this season in a different
context like it's a part of the before it was like
part of the personality of the show embodying the
80s and this really just feels like a horror show
now and not you know the 80s nostalgia show at all
yeah the 80s wonder show yeah yeah and you know
like billy being in a band and not billy um uh
danny well who's the freaking guy dungeons and
dragons guy danny his name freddy freddy that's
danny is it freddy freddy i think confident
about that i'm pretty sure it's not danny
is there another danny in the show i'm not sure
what were you gonna say i'll look it up you might
be right i think it's freddy the freak yes um with
him being in a band and then also this emphasis
on music channeling a different part of your
brain and i think that's something a lot of us
can relate to hence why slapping 80s music onto a
show taking place in the easy so nostalgic and you
talk about the soundtrack so there's a bit of like
this interesting meta commentary about that with
dealing with the psychology of why nostalgic how
to work so well and then especially for stranger
things a show that was so popular and one of the
biggest talks about it was it was so nostalgic
for the 80s and then using a song to help save the
day capturing that part in your brain activating
it is a big and leading to this uh action of love
and hope during a time of such great harrowing um
just like beautiful harrowing visuals by
the way that was like absolutely beautiful
at the same time as nightmarish as it was
as it's like messed up as it was it's still
beautiful to behold and i think it's cool
that they managed to there's not been anything
about have fun 80s song it's it did the music
using that as a part of the actual character
for your show is great great choice uh all
around and this is it just gets more horror as
it descends with horror genre tropes of the
supernatural haunting and but then it also felt
most stranger things horror here because it's
almost like we're in the upside down than
before yeah yeah yeah absolutely and i thought
running running up that hill and especially using
like the the kate bush version and all that
stuff like i thought that was a really nicely
chosen song because you know i feel like there are
always debates to be had about deliberate use of
music and when lyrics reflect too heavily of what
the plot is doing but i thought that was a well
song for just all her character beats because it
definitely sinks over and lines up with both uh
you know her wishing she could have swapped places
with billy but also just that you know again the
motif of literally running up some kind of you
know obstacle uh and just the fact that that is
an iconic song like i could see how that would be
somebody's favorite song at the time and uh yeah i
thought it was a really nice thematic choice in
a really great way like you said to build upon
the you know motifs and the language of the show
and then make that stuff more meaningful and uh
and yeah and i thought it was a really nicely
uh i thought it was really nice the way they
orchestrated that as part of the solution or as
part of the way we can fight back against vector
like it felt like a very natural unfolding of that
and using the motif of okay we're in his flashback
and uh you know ella fitzgerald is playing and so
that's the sort of clue and uh going back through
that too like the whole flashback with creel
and getting like you said like a little american
horror story-esque interlude where you're in the
past and you're seeing the onset of at least the
first time we're aware of this having happened
you know recently and uh i thought he turned in
a great performance too like he basically gets
to give this big old monologue that is then
filled in with some cutaways and such but
you know it's like vecna itself is such a
monstrous presence and is that are we to assume
that's robert england doing the voice of becna
yeah we established that since the first episode
oh i guess so i just wasn't 100 certain but
uh either way i mean i i thought that uh that
yeah like having him in a subtle way he's got
the bigger hand on the one side with the claws
there's like that little subtle freddie nod but
this also reminds you of just how good of an actor
robert england can be and how affecting he can be
and uh you know is he also creel he's cruel
yeah yeah yeah well that's why i was asking
because i was like okay i can definitely tell
oh i thought they were asking about vector yeah
no that's yeah cause vecna i'm like okay he
must be doing the voice but i don't think he's
in the makeup unless he is in the middle
no they did establish that he would be um
i think they they i think the duffer brothers um
said that he would be creel yeah yeah absolutely
but i didn't know if he was the voice of the
yeah the monster uh as well to play a human
they cover up his eyes i know but i mean even
still that was a great as it is a really good
looking effect and he really was able to emote
through that and i love the tension that they
got out of that whole sequence because
you get the fun and games of them having
to break in and ingratiate themselves and then
yeah you get your silence of the lambs sort of
you know unnerving interlude with him uh and
yeah there's the way that that progresses while
filling in the blanks i thought was really well
done too it's so tension this is like the most
intense season it is so intense uh yeah i really
love it and i think that there's like such great
little subtleties that are i think are fantastic
you know even when mike and will will looking
up at mike as mike is feeling a little bit
more like the mic that we've all come to love
a softer mic not just complaining mike but a
softer mic yeah and will just always been such
a lost soul and he always found like a sense of
ground and feeling grounded with his friends yeah
you know and being in this new state we're still
feeling a bit like an outsider or not in his place
of comfort you know the part where he felt he
most belonged and felt safe was with his friends
and to have mike you know confide in him and tell
him like we can do this together just feeling like
this is where i belong it's really a touching
moment or even lucas and all these times of him
trying to get max to connect to him
and seeing like you can talk to me
and sometimes it could be like a little bit
desperate but then you see in this moment that
if it wasn't for lucas being there knowing
max so well to be able to find the song choice
to help save her like he does know and love her
and then protects her i think the way they write
that whole grieving thing because like i really
like the monologue max is giving when she's
reading the letter yeah uh and then i i did
find my mind kind of trailing off a little bit
a couple points though going i remember this
billy guy being a complete abusive [__] to
you and there was that whole thing in season two
where you like uh uh you you drugged him i mean
when he was like beating up steve you told him
not to mess with you again throwing him in the
bat he was like a total dick yeah you know and
and and it's so and then he was the villain
he granted he was being embodied uh by uh upside
down thinking magic my player uh yeah he was
yeah so what i appreciated was that they really
painted the gray of what it's like to lose someone
who is abusive to you who is also family of you do
have the good memories and you do have the wishful
things you do have i i imagine we could have had
this and that and it could have been beautiful
but then what he's praying on is the other side
that can really make you feel guilty which is
i'm kind of relieved that you died because you
were awful you know you can't hurt me anymore
yeah yeah and i thought that was such a a
great way to flesh out her grief you know
because it's not like she's confessing and saying
goodbye and trying to really put this to rest with
her letter it's oh it's all this other stuff
she's not acknowledging that he can feed off of
because that's a hard thing to admit uh when
you're like i'm kind of relieved my brother died
when you know it's like we know that yeah billy
was messed up yeah um and knew how to make her
feel bad always like especially in season two
their relationship he was insanely abusive
yeah so uh yeah maybe bill was a great character
like dr montgomery was freaking awesome to have
his presence back was nice yeah every little
cameo yeah um so yeah i thought it was great and
they had a great action scene too with the with
the go with the runner yeah the one with that i
was like where did this cool scene come from like
this coffee is just a joke i'm like you're badass
you're taking out the whole military yeah yeah
yeah you're thinking about all these soldiers yeah
no i mean netflix you know obviously it's like
a meme about their shows but i thought that was
another one of like wow you really stepped up for
this one like it yeah as much as it is easy to go
like ah netflix wonder it was a really impressive
and really visceral and intense sequence and yeah
it's nice to get uh maybe jonathan being a
little more important yeah he's the one who's
initiated that yeah yeah and this is also except
for flashbacks a a a nearly 11-less episode right
we don't even check in with her in the present
once now in some ways this is like their walking
dead or game of thrones season where you just like
yes don't check it with other characters that's
absolutely a good call and then friggin a i mean
everything with joyce and murray and and yuri
and and the double cross i mean i guess we we
could have done them i know i did i didn't either
like i kept i couldn't see that i kept every step
of the way i kept being like okay it's gonna be
this thing or there won't be enough money or
something like that and then yeah just comes
right down to the double cross so uh i don't
know that's easy that that situation only seems
like it can get crazier and more complicated
well it's interesting they kept things like
a little bit fun despite inspire despite some
stuff that was occasionally horrific with the
you know the dream sequences with becca with max
they kept a lot of it fun because these episodes
are so thick yeah so there's they structure
them differently than before um it's fun and
then you come back to russia with hopper that's
when it's really like realistic and intense you
feel the biting like there's no there's no real
stranger things going on over there yeah you know
in terms of sci-fi stuff that's why i keep going
what about the demogorgon you know isn't there
a big demogorgon maybe that's where they would
escape prisoners and corrupt guards i was thinking
so yeah you have that and then the way they
are tying it into the events like they had the
russians in season all throughout season three but
this time they're actually scary well yeah right
and and yeah and and the even joyce's involvement
and murray's involvement have ramifications from
that previous season because clearly the kgb is
very much aware of them a thousand percent yeah
and uh the way to build on that and you know i did
think hopper would get away that was also a good
fight scene too yeah i thought hopper was going
to get away and they they sell you on it like oh
he can finally relax he puts his feet under the
blanket eats the peanut butter he feels relieved
yeah oh it's like suffering sobbing into peanut
butter only yeah to get apprehended immediately
yeah i mean i feel like the guards would have
thought that through why did the warden call him
the yuri why the warden called yuri
he said the warden called me or did he call the
warden he called yeah yeah he called the warden
yeah he just said don't call here yeah yuri called
yuri called the warden well he called that oh
yeah but yuri called the warden beforehand
to let him know that uh our guy is corrupt
and is helping hopper i think he reported
i thought he said the warding called him
uh maybe but the i don't know the way i took that
scene was he said i called the warden and ratted
on you to make the money for ratting on you i
gotta know this i gotta know i'm pretty sure
he said the warding called me all right check it i
must know not to prove you wrong or something john
just i feel like it changes the context a lot
in that scene eddie munson it's not freddie it's
eddie munson eddie here we go we can verify that
and then we can verify this don't worry someone
already put down a comment correcting us yes
eddie munson yeah that's the way it goes man let
me just speed through this i'm very sorry i just
thought you should the side changing plan come on
speeding this up oh i just got the phone
with the board a very productive call okay
so so yeah he just snitched
on him bastard yeah [__] a
i trusted the corrupt guy to have a good
corrupt liaison i mean i imagine that they would
i mean you guys probably finished the show it's
not week to week yeah don't i mean it so it won't
matter if you comment because we'll probably
be past this point anyway i mean i'll i'll say
this that i think the trailers did ruin something
then ah okay because you do see yeah yeah trying
to damn try not to think too hard it wasn't even
no i just remember that i remember because yeah
do we see him back i mean we see murray and
joyce on a plane okay kind of intensely oh
so they're probably going to overpower yuri damn
uh that sucks wasn't like a leak yeah that's all
right that's just like the trailer yeah there's
other shots with hopper that i that are coming
to mind that they were like big in the promos in
the beginning that have not come to fruition yeah
that's just funny about me is like movies that can
weirdly handle spoilers now and leaks i don't like
actively seek them but if it happens like
i don't know um if the movie is good enough
the moment will hit but a show is i'm way more
particular about a show for some reason a show
because it's a longer investment a bigger
investment yeah especially this season yeah
i'd rather not know with a show yeah yeah 100 yeah
yeah um that that's something that weirdly irks me
a lot that irks me a lot more i i like oh just
keep it away from me i don't want to yeah um but
uh this is another great episode uh thank you guys
so much for being here and i don't know what day
of the week this is that this is going up should
we just do the rest of the patron call-outs sure
let's shout out some patrons yeah fan pops always
getting chased by the cops olivia del guy sharing
french fries with me andy funk is never in a skunk
the lorenzo baxter foundation corporation read
richard this is a fantastic form why are you here
differently sane what is it that you have to gain
that's the heavenly smell of levitt odell somehow
finding our patreon she charted a course as she
ventured on her lauren american horse i could
never be jaded when i'm hanging with simply faded
i never say no no to peter pacheco co you're the
one from me joanna saint louis let's climb a tree
you know what makes me feel free
when i hang out with mr ro cree
we want to fight like jackie chan and bruce lee
knock me to the floor getting picked up by sj90
justin martin always showing
up here angry like cartman
rosie beatty is not a nosy lady she's
she's lovely and you should get to know
phillip j smith jr always kicking it with
all these boomers he jumped into puberty
a little bit late call him a late bloomer
speaking of calling i'm calling the punk
calling to call me backpack jen
smith don't know what rhymes
melanie leblanc on getting
cronk that's right badonka
talk turn your phone notifications off
jason dolan when are you and i gonna go
bowling when i put my finger
inside of you we call that hole
we do call it holland and uh
we would love to be holland
all of you thank you guys so much for being here
we love you we appreciate your support every month
and for sticking with us through
this nonsense we'll see you guys soon